>>> TWITTER HAS ANNOUNCED ITS
DISBANDED ITS TRUST AND SAFETY
COUNCIL FORMED TO DEAL WITH HATE
SPEECH, TERRORISM, CHILD
EXPLOITATION.
IT IS THE LATEST SHAKEUP OF
TWITTER SINCE PURCHASED BY ELON
MUSK.
THE NEW POLICIES AND RECENT
RELEASE OF THE DOCUMENTS ARE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE BETTER
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT HOW THE
COMPANY OPERATES, PARTICULARLY
AFTER CONTENT POLICIES IN THE
2020 ELECTION.
CRITICS ARE SAYING MUSK AND HIS
ALLIES ARE MISREPRESENTING THE
WORK OF TWITTER'S FORMER
MANAGEMENT WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICING CONTACT ON THE SOCIAL
MEDIA NETWORK.
A LOT TO TAKE IN AND UNDERSTAND
WHICH IS WHY WE ASKED SULLIVAN
TO MAKE SENSE OF IT.
HERE'S HIS REPORT.
>> I GOT SICK OF TWITTER.
>> GOT CENSORED TOO MUCH.
SHE WAS IN TWITTER JAIL EVERY
OTHER DAY.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICANS LONG
BELIEVED SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
LIKE TWITTER ARE BIASSED AGAINST
THEM.
>> SHADOW BAN, 100%.
LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Reporter: ENTER THE TWITTER
FILES.
JOURNALISTS HAVE BEEN GIVEN
ACCESS TO TWITTER'S INTERNAL
SYSTEMS AND COMMUNICATIONS.
MATT IS ONE OF THEM.
>> THEY HAVE A WHOLE UNIVERSE OF
STUFF THAT THEY CAN DO TO ANY
SINGLE ACCOUNT.
THEY CAN DIAL IT ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO YOU CANNOT BE SEARCHED
ALL THE WAY UP TO YOUR ACCOUNT
WILL NOT TREND.
ONLY PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW YOU CAN
SEE YOU.
EVEN PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW YOU WON'T
SEE YOU UNLESS THEY SEARCH.
>> Reporter: SO FAR SELECT
IMAGES LIKE THESE PURPORT TO
SHOW HOW SOME PROMINENT
CONSERVATIVES WERE ADDED TO DO
NOT AMPAMPLIFY.
BUT FEW SPECIFICS WERE INCLUDED
IN THE FILES.
>> WE WERE AVERAGING 115,000
RETWEETS A DAY WHEN WE WERE AT
OUR PEAK.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, WE STOPPED OFF
A CLIFF ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
OUR ENGAGEMENT, OUR RETWEETS
DISAPPEARED.
>> Reporter: TWEETER
ACKNOWLEDGED IT DEAMPLIFIED
ACCOUNTS IT VIEWS AS HARMFUL,
BUT IT DOES NOT TELL THE USERS
THE ACCOUNTS ARE BEING LIMITED.
MUSK WANTS TO CHANGE THAT.
>> MUSK TALKED ABOUT INFORMING
PEOPLE OF REMOVAL AND REDUCTION,
AND THAT IS A GOOD THING.
BUT IT IS NOT CLEAR HOW HE'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO HAVE THE
ENGINEERING AND THE RESOURCES TO
DO IT.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS
TRANSPARENCY IS A GOOD THING.
THERE IS SOME CASES WHERE IT IS
BETTER TO NOT INFORM A USER
THEIR ACCOUNT IS BEING LIMITED,
SUCH AS THE CASE OF SERIAL
HARASSERS.
>> WE LOOK AT THE KINDS OF
ACCOUNTS THAT TWITTER HAS
DEAMPLIFIED OR BANNED OVER THE
LAST TWO OR THREE YEARS.
IT TENDS TO BE ACCOUNTS THAT
WILL POST THINGS THAT ARE BOTH
NOVEL AND OUTRAGEOUS AND
DETRIMENTAL IN SOME WAY TO
NOTICE, WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
HATE, HARASSMENT OR INCITEMENT.
>> Reporter: WHAT IS
DEAMPLIFICATION.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU OPEN YOUR
TWITTER FEED, YOU'RE NOT SEEING
THE LATEST TWEET.
YOU'RE SEEING THE ALGORITHM
RECOMMENDING ACCOUNTS AND THINGS
YOU MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN.
NOW LET'S IMAGINE TWITTER IS
SOMETIMES SQUARE.
PEOPLE HERE CAN SAY WHATEVER
THEY WANT TO WHOEVER THEY WANT.
BUT SOMETIMES THE ALGORITHM
MIGHT PICK UP THE MORE
INTERESTING COMMENTS AND TWEETS
AND HIGHLIGHT THEM ON THE
BILLBOARDS.
IF YOU ARE BLACKLISTED YOU WILL
NEVER GET YOUR COMMENTS OR
TWEETS UP ON THESE BILLBOARDS.
THAT'S WHAT SOME PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND TO BE SHADOW BANNING.
>> SHADOW BANNING HAS A LOT OF
NEGATIVE CONNOTATIONS.
IT BRINGS UP THIS IMAGE OF A
SHADOWY CABAL OF DECISION MAKERS
WHO DETERMINE WHAT PEOPLE CAN
SEE AND WHAT PEOPLE CAN'T SEE.
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY NOT A
PRODUCTIVE WORD TO USE WHEN
WE'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE NUANCES OF
CONTENT POLICY.
>> Reporter: WHILE MANY GROUPS
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT
DEAMPLIFICATIONS, SOME PEOPLE
THINK REPUBLICANS WERE LONG
TARGETED.
THAT IS SOMETHING TWITTER
DENIED.
>> TWITTER UNDERTOOK NO BEHAVIOR
TO SELECTIVELY CENSOR
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS OR
CONSERVATIVE VOICES ON YOUR
PLATFORM.
THAT IS CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE NOT
CONVINCED, PARTICULARLY AFTER
TWITTER INITIALLY SUPPRESSED THE
2020 NEW YORK POST HUNTER BIDEN
STORY BELIEVING IT COULD HAVE
BEEN RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
THAT IS SOMETHING JACK DORSEY
SAYS A MISTAKE.
SO TOO WAS THE FORMER HEAD OF
TRUST AND SAFETY.
>> IT IS WIDELY REPORTED THAT I
PERSONALLY DIRECTED THE
SUPPRESSION OF THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY UNEQUIVOCALLY
UNTRUE.
>> Reporter: BUT HE WAS INVOLVED
IN INTERNAL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
IT.
HOW STAFF AT TWITTER DISCUSSED
AND DEBATED HOW TO HANDLE THE
BIDEN STORY.
>> WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO
BELIEVE.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS TRUE.
THERE WAS SMOKE.
AND ULTIMATELY FOR ME, IT DIDN'T
REACH A PLACE WHERE I WAS
COMFORTABLE REMOVING THIS
CONTENT FROM TWITTER.
>> SO IT WAS A MISTAKE?
>> IN MY OPINION YES.
>> Reporter: MUSK HIMSELF
TWITTING FREEDOM OF SPEECH BUT
NOT FREEDOM OF REACH.
HATE SPEECH WILL BE MAX
DEBOOSTED.
>> THESE TOOLS WHICH HAVE BEEN
AROUND FOR SOME TIME HAVE BEEN
POLITICIZED AND AS MUSK IS
TRYING TO SUGGEST THAT THE OLD
TWITTER IS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
FROM THE NEW TWITTER, WE WANT TO
BE CAREFUL TO REMIND OURSELVES
THAT ALL TECHNOLOGY IS
POLITICKED BY OTHER MEANS.
>> I MEAN, IS IT CLEARER THAT
REPUBLICANS WERE TARGETED?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, WELL, THAT IS CERTAINLY
WHAT IS BEING PRESENTED HERE
THROUGH THE TWITTER FILES.
PEOPLE I THINK MIGHT ARGUE THAT
IT IS JUST A SELECTION AND WHAT
IS BEING PRESENTED IS SELECTIVE.
PEOPLE THAT WORKED AT TWITTER AT
THE TIME WILL SAY THE REASON WE
HAD TO TAKE ACTION OR THE REASON
WE THOUGHT WE HAD TO TAKE ACTION
AGAINST PEOPLE THAT THOUGHT THEY
WERE REPUBLICANS IS THEY WERE
OFTEN PEOPLE SHARING
MISINFORMATION, DISINFORMATION
OR HATE.
ALL THAT BEING SAID, THERE ARE
REVELATIONS IN THIS THAT ARE
BEING PRESENTED AS BRAND-NEW,
WHICH WE ACTUALLY KNEW ABOUT FOR
THE PAST FEW YEARS.
THAT BEING SAID, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE SEEN SOME PEOPLE SAY THIS
IS ALL A NOTHING BURGER.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE CASE
HERE.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, GO BACK TO
2021, JANUARY 2021 WHEN TWITTER
DID KICK OFF THE THEN PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT WASN'T JUST, YOU KNOW,
REPUBLICANS HERE IN THE U.S. WHO
HAD AN ISSUE WITH THAT, ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL POWER OF BIG TECH.
WE HEARD EUROPEAN LEADERS SPOKE
FIRST ANGELA MERKEL AT THE TIME,
NO BIG FAN OF TRUMP'S EXPRESSING
SOME CONCERN ABOUT THAT.
THERE IS A DISCUSSION TO BE HAD
HERE, AND WE ARE GOING TO SEE